now the two separate incidences had
plenty of reaction from Neighbors and
while no officers were hurt three men
are now dead
officer-involved shootings happened
Friday night the first happening here in
this desert shorts Community around 7 30
PM after Metro Police received reports
of a man with a gun outside of his home
once police arrived that man pointing
his gun at officers refusing to stand
down that's when police Drew their
weapons and fired shots killing him
residents in the neighborhood recall
what they heard along with how well they
knew the man involved my daughters and I
we were sitting down having Sabbath
dinner and we heard you know three very
loud distinct gunshots we knew what they
were but I didn't think that they were
right here on the Block I used to see
him all the time hello come the mailbox
is right here used to come to the
mailbox
but he seemed like a decent guy then
another officer-involved shooting
happened later in the evening in the
southwest Valley when a Metro SWAT team
officer shot and killed a man who had
taken a hostage that same man wanted in
connection to a fatal shooting earlier
that afternoon at that hostage and the
suspect were currently in the area of
the 6200 block of West Spring Mountain
Road
due to the rapidly evolving situation
SWAT was requested to the area as a
result we were able to rescue the
hostage unharmed a SWAT officer fired
his weapon and that suspect is currently
deceased here on scene the initial
shooting involving that suspect happened
on Kipling Street near Jones and the
us-95 where a man was found shot to
death inside of a home that home right
across the way from neighbor Pete Mackey
who's lived in the neighborhood for 20
years it was a little scary to come home
and see the entire neighborhood roped
off and not knowing what was going on
and I kind of walked into the aftermath
of it now currently no details have been
given about the two suspects or the man
found dead inside of the home but
Friday's shooting marks the 11th and
12th officer-involved shooting of 2022
from Metro Police Department in The
Newsroom Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now